[Music]
I'm not allowed to use magic outside of
school Harry tells Hedwig he can't use
magic to open the cage to let him out
but there's a key in the lock
he's turning a key magic how do you how
does the house-elf like Dobby get out of
the house so often to steal letters from
Harry's friends
has he been wandering around outside
snatching owls out of the air and why
did he even bring these letters with him
in the first place if you wanted to keep
Harry from Hogwarts the company
downstairs could hear Dobby when he hit
his head against the drawers earlier but
can't hear anything is Harry and Dobby
run down the stairs there's no way in
hell Harry hears this flying car the
only way he could have been woken up
just in time to see it is you guessed it
magic hey George thanks for the roll
call Harry yet Ron threatened Georgia
home but so are a host of other reasons
so where are they on this GPS system
Harry and Ron had a whole year to get to
know each other and Ron's dad's job
never came up
and who are you seriously one of the
most famous wizards in all the land and
Arthur Weasley who works with the
government hasn't even so much as seen a
picture of Harry it's not won't come
cheap mom is there any reason this
family full of magical wizard still has
to be Poor's like can they not use a
textbook creating spell or something I
mean we've got self-cleaning pots and
pans here people what could this family
possibly need money for there's even a
spell to fix the lens and your
eyeglasses for fuck's sake
wouldn't Harry have to be like American
to mispronounce a Diagon Alley the way
he does helps advance the plot to have
him end up somewhere else sure but it's
completely stupid that he would
mispronounce it this way Harry just
happens to get accidentally sent to a
place where he can overhear the malifaux
he's being evil please maybe they should
have called this Harry Potter and the
Chamber of plot conveniences this run
through the brick is cute no but are we
honestly supposed to believe that no
muggles ever see this and freak the
out calling 999 to report the redheaded
kids are just completely evaporated in
broad daylight like for instance these
models here who clearly see Harry and
Ron's failed attempt at going through
the brick what haven't you ever seen a
bunch of kids run through brick before
booster must be faulty yeah because
magic invisibility can break down just
like windshield wipers or air
conditioning this car doesn't get dented
or crushed at all
now you can tell me it's a magical car
and that it can't get damaged but then
I'll tell you that the car only crash
because it was damaged something oh now
the tree can dent the car I know they
had a brief adventure with the tree but
why are they so much later in arriving
than the students were on the train
which they followed here and presumably
arrived at the same time does everybody
in this movie carry around with them and
expose incriminating items in this story
in this shop there are panels open
everywhere in this greenhouse including
a huge Beanstalk or something coming out
of this one but then when the camera
actually goes down into the greenhouse
none of the panels are open so we one
meandering screen causes the whole class
to put their hands over their ears while
wearing earmuffs but 30 Mandrake's all
screaming at once brings no discomfort
whatsoever man this kid has the best
eyesight and unnecesary expositional
abilities of any wizard in Hogwarts how
the did he recognize Iran's owl
from this distance and where the because
it's all coming from anyway I don't
quite understand if your block heart and
you're a well-known author who has women
throwing themselves at you and you're
this vain why would you take a
low-paying job as a teacher at Hogwarts
Gilderoy Lockhart inception painting
little quiz doesn't hawk words set a
curriculum like how can professors come
in and give quizzes about themselves to
the students without that getting out
and the professor getting reprimanded
better way to serve detention and by
helping me to answer my fan mail I
wonder if this nearly 3 hour movie will
have time to explain how they and
Lockhart is look at the time we've been
here for hours ok Harry was in detention
with Lockhart for four hours and then
gets out late at night conveniently
bumps into his two friends and then BAM
all the kids in the entire school
happened upon the scene at that exact
moment does McDonough Ville write
backwards on the chalkboard to make
learning even more of a challenge for
her students ah another super useful
spell that's something you probably need
on an everyday basis the air alone would
be able to open the chamber and unleash
the horror within and by so doing purge
the school of all those who in
residents view but unworthy to study
magic like Filch's cat why would the
school around to keep performing magic
with this wand it seems like it would be
a danger to himself and everyone around
him and why doesn't a school full of
magical items have like a spare wand
lying around somewhere that this poor
bastard can use Hermione Ron and Hagrid
get from the stands to filled in seven
seconds Wow
also thank God Hermione is the only
alert responsible person in the whole
school how incredibly convenient for our
heroes and how terribly inconvenient for
all the girls in the school to have
their bathroom choices narrowed down
wand goes whine but then is magically
back in Lockhart's hand after he lands
and we all know Lockhart doesn't know
enough magic to pull that trick off
if I hadn't told that snake not to
attack just yes there was absolutely no
one who could have stopped that snake
from attacking Justin I mean no one you
would have done well in Slytherin
I get the sense that Slytherin needs to
rebrand itself I mean everything
associated with Slytherin is evil all
the evil kids go here if you're sent a
Slytherin the school's basically saying
you're a bad kid have fun being an
asshole
Ted the snake monster and the Chamber of
Secrets must be waiting weeks between
victims we had the cat than the picture
kid and the dark haired dude and it's
Christmas isn't he on some kind of
crusade to kill all the mud bloods man
it sure is lucky there's a time and
place to catch Crabbe and Goyle walking
alone in the hallways and trick them
with floating cupcake bait this super
complicated potion that took a month to
create apparently does not need to be
measured or administered in any specific
amount follow the fighters hacker tells
the kids to go into the dark forest
which he surely knows has a bunch of
ravenous spiders waiting to kill them
never opened the Chamber of Secrets to
clear his name the defense calls to the
stand
this giant spider hill cleared up I
believe in magic cars with invisibility
buttons I really do but I don't believe
in a magic car that somehow knows its
owner is endangering comes roaring in to
save the day
oh come on she's been in here for weeks
but not one doctor nurse or professor
check to see if there was a large wadded
up piece of paper in her hand but if it
kills by looking people in the eye
why is it no one's dead because no one
did look it in the eye Collins saw it
through his camera Justin must have seen
the basilisk through nearly headless
Nick and Hermione had the mirror how
mrs. Norris there was water on the floor
that night this is the most convenient
and luckiest set of circumstances ever
for numerous characters to defy death
spiders flee before this page about the
basilisk clearly states that the crowing
of the rooster can kill it but instead
of seeing that important information
harry focuses on the spiders flee from
it and ends up going into the Chamber of
Secrets completely rooster listen also
why were the spider is running out of
Hagrid's cabinet where was the basilisk
during match how does she know which
student was taken the message just says
her without mentioning a name it's
completely illogical that Dumbledore
would ever have hired a bumbling useless
wizard like Lockhart to be any kind of
teacher at Hogwarts so we can get back
through Ron neither has the wand nor the
arms to move substantial amounts of rock
from this pile how does a memory
generate it from a diary pick up Harry's
wand and if you can do that why doesn't
he do anything else to Harry that might
have made killing him easier so how did
Fox the Phoenix get past the spot where
the rocks caved in and blocked the path
but snake door that Harry had to speak
Parseltongue to open the door clearly
closes behind it main character trips
and falls while running away from evil
cliche Ginny you need to get yourself
out follow the chamber and you'll find
drone trapped behind a wall of fallen
rock that you can't get past stop there
and wait for more instructions you must
have shown me real loyalty down in the
chamber nothing with that could've
called forestry well it's either that or
the convenient storytelling why would
Malfoy we bring Dobby along on this
angry visit to Dumbledore's office so
the rule is the house elf becomes free
when the master presents him with
clothes is this really presenting
clothes to Dobby does Malfoy have to
specify every time he gives Dobby a
basket of laundry now these aren't your
clothes Dobby these are for cleaning
this is all accidental and without the
Masters knowledge this rule and this
loophole of stupid
I know we want to have a nice Dobby
saves Harry moment here at the end but
was Lucius Malfoy seriously about to use
the death curse on Harry right here
outside double doors office Oh exams
have been canceled you didn't learn
anything anyway Disney slow clap finale
cliche
goodbye Dumbledore hope you don't look
and sound completely different next time
I see you okay now let's take a look at
how negligent the school is after
filches canidates petrified Dumbledore
says he strongly recommends caution at
this point there should at least be some
beefed up security and possibly some
education about petrification now the
school's Jimmy Olsen is petrified
Dumbledore now says danger is no longer
safe it is as we feared Chamber of
Secrets has indeed being open again the
answer let's teach students self-defense
techniques but not against some possible
monster which might know something like
I don't know petrification but against
each other and using this dumbass
lockhart who by this time everyone knows
is a fraud and of course they learned
nothing except that harry can speak
Parseltongue the school forgets about
that no longer safe decree nobody
patrols the halls Baltimore can
apparently just guide Ginny Weasley
around the school's halls petrifying
cats and wizards and painting messages
and blood and there's a one person who
ever witnesses it now it's business as
usual again and this kid Justin gets
petrified
Dumbledore knows it's not Potter now
there's been three incidents but there's
still no evacuation to the school and
still no extra security the Gryffindor
House is ransacked and who does Neville
go to well he goes to Harry because not
one adult here seems to give a about any
I mean these assholes were about to play
Quidditch again and there's a monster
crawling around at the school but it
gets canceled because Hermione is now
petrified so now a captain three people
have been petrified and the school
remains open and not one kid is scared
of sheep in this entire school and
they're casually sitting around on their
dorms without a care in the world then
there's this ludicrous new set of rules
that come out be back at your house by
6:00 okay whatever but every student
will be accompanied by a teacher to
every lesson sorry no way that happens
did you see how many teachers are at
this school no well McGonagall makes an
announcement that the students need to
go back to their dorms and all the
teachers come up to the second-floor
corridor where they could see the new
message do you see how many people show
up it's six including a dwarf and this
asshole Filch we find out Jenny Weasley
has been taken by the monster and only
now does McGonagall say students must be
sent home I'm afraid this is the end of
Hogwarts they forget about all that once
Lockhart shows up telling him he finally
has a chance to slay the Beast knowing
well he doesn't have the ability as an
evacuation ordered of course not
[Applause]
[Music]
most mothers aren't accustomed to seeing
a flying car right
[Applause]
[Music]